you look terrific yeah what what are you
what are you doing are you well I was no
no no I have lost 50 pounds it was
because good yeah it's just because they
told me that I had diabetes high blood
pressure and high cholesterol at the
same time so basically all I can eat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I would love to doctor's appointment
gluten Wow okay so speaking of which
yeah relationships you were engaged yes
and you broke off that engagement
recently is that you yeah that's
absolutely true that was this a painful
thing or kind of amicable oh yeah it was
really it was fine it was perfectly fine
I know you of course your engagement all
right yeah was that like did you throw a
dance party some people are quite
relieved people realize we're not in the
right space together in Woody Allen
movie Woody Allen movies are always like
yeah whatever you know I'm getting
nauseous and me too with in the other
separate ways it's possible you could
have a whole variety of emotions no are
you brilliant I was screaming but no no
you know the thing is it's easier for us
because I am oh I'm a lesbian I know
that's shocking but and you know we have
a time-honored tradition of keeping our
exes as friends that's very close friend
or staying friends yeah we're staying
friends oh I have my ways I have at
least nine X's that are my friends which
is good because you never know when
somebody's gonna want to throw a really
good game of softball yeah okay are you
saying lesbians are always close with
the person they break up yeah absolutely
they always travel in a group always in
a pack it's a big group and it's been my
thing to try to figure out what to call
a group of lesbians you know like a
gaggle of geese I think it's a lick
[Laughter]
it's a ram of right those are the two
like so you got this award I'm learning
all kinds of words all right well okay
so your butt your hat you're in a good
place you're gonna meet someone else now
you're on the prowl no no no no no no
I'm not gonna meet anyone else I'm
resigned to where I am I am the lesbian
Jack Nicholson that is Who I am
because I can't be the lesbian Brad Pitt
yeah I'm 58 years old so I'm the lesbian
Jack Nicholson I think Brad Pitt I think
that's Rachel Maddow I think she's the
lesbian Brad Pitt okay and as I'm and I
picked Jack pickles and very carefully
because Jack was like six years old then
he had babies by two different
twenty-something year old women the same
year I think I'm right
so you want to be you want to have many
partners have a lot of fun no I just
want to get two girls pregnant okay well
you just did something not a lot of
people do in this business which I
commend you for you said your age and by
the way 58 you look amazing
thank you yeah what can I say it's from
good genes I'll tell you it is not for
taking care of myself so what you do
it's all in the genes kids know do you
have a secret you soon it's the lesbian
thing again that's when we it's it's a
queer thing it's one of the few actual
perks that we have you know sure we are
ostracized by our friends and by society
and our family we are often killed in
the street but at least way.you we look
10 years younger than we actually are
I mean but why I was like no no kids no
men no wrinkles is what I'm gonna go
with sorry yeah yeah all right they
don't have the stress that we have yeah
well well I have the stress that you
have because I happen to be with women
so I think you understand
oh my god did I say something sexist no
wait I don't even know I'm not sure just
you know for yourself away from the sex
you